it was a chaotic end to the school day
for students at western high school
today two juveniles were shot by ccsd
police when police say the car they were
in drove toward officers victoria saha
spoke exclusively to one of the teens
inside that car but madison kimbrough
starts our team coverage to explain what
police say happened
an intense afternoon here at western
high school as this area you're about to
see of bonanza was completely blocked
off for hours as one student was hit and
two others taken to the hospital
[Music]
i was driving down the street and i
noticed a bunch of ambulances fire
trucks police i called my wife asked her
what happened she was already at the
school picking up her daughter so i was
kind of shocked tuesday afternoon a
chaotic situation at western high school
around 2 15 p-m c-c-s-d-p-d received a
tip about a car with a weapon on campus
grounds speeding a car was observed at a
high rate of speed entering the parking
lot our officers ordered that vehicle to
stop but the car kept speeding through
making a u-turn thus hitting a female
student and then continuing to speed
towards police our officers gave orders
for the vehicle to stop one of the
officers pulled his service weapon fired
rounds at the car which then continued
towards him made a right turn and then
exited the parking lot two teens in that
car who were both shot were taken to the
hospital by their parents one at umc and
the other at sunrise hospital both are
expected to survive some western high
parents say they didn't know what was
unfolding at the school which made for a
stressful pickup we get nervous because
we we don't have the opportunity to to
know what how our kids are no we don't
have any information by email the school
is
very very conservative they don't share
information with the parents i send a
test to my daughter and she already
responds and say she said something
happened but i don't know what happened
luckily the student that was hit by the
car is not seriously injured and no
officers were hurt during the incident
reporting live near western high school
madison kimbrough live local now